so we've been working all day and we  thought we'd take a little break and  Magnus suggested that we play a little  game called kanessa shucks and what that  is is flicking chess so you actually  flick the pieces trying to take the  other person's King so I'll bring in our  special guests now to show you how it's  done  Wow  this realm of physics Delhi Festa yeah  yeah yeah yeah the rooks end up very  strong in this game I'm gonna try oh can  I put it on the Thunder  Marie Murphy is this towards the center  let's try together new queen doesn't  work that way hmm got to learn the rules  to play the game  ah that was Chuck I was very good at  this too much spin on that one okay hmm  difficult then just leave our kingdom  yeah I think I've it's difficult to get  to the bishop nice now you leave me with  a clear shot of the king ah blunder